[Musique]
quand gildas arzel reçoit la maison il y
a toujours une guitare pas loin
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le loiret dans la bosse
ici pendant cinq ans gildas et ses amis
musiciens ont réalisé un album country
j'habite un village qui s'appelle grève
il j'ai trouvé que ça sonnait un peu
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il ya une ville
américaine à côté jeffrey papier mais
qui s'appelle green ville donc c'était
marrant de de faire sonner un petit peu
un titre qui ressemble à un truc
américain alors qu'en fait c'est un
village le plus france est possible
il ya des tas de gens qui lisent en
anglais en fait en beauce
les jours
[Musique]
mais pour les moins de 20 ans qui ne le
connaissent pas bien petit rappel il y a
trente ans gildas arzel c'était ça
[Musique]
et à la fin des années 80 gildas croiser
la route d'un certain jean jacques
goldman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une amitié voit le jour
dix ans plus tard golman participe même
activement au troisième album sur l'eau
de son ami le disque est prêt et gildas
va faire une proposition
quand on écoute les chansons au mixage
et me dit ouais c'est bien tu vas tu vas
vraiment amusé sur scène et je lui dis
ben pourquoi tu viens pas oui bah non je
peux pas te rends compte ça va être
compliqué les gens s'y est sage et j'ai
dit c'est toi qui vois et puis
finalement il a réfléchi mais des bons
aux tentes
ma compagne et je joue du violon de la
guitare des coeurs comme ça donc on a
dit sans le dire en dix ans pour qu'ils
passent que pour pas pour pas que les
gens attendent à ce que ce que
jean-jacques chante ses titres quoi donc
ils pouvaient voir ça comme un dieu ou
de pouvoir c'était compliqué à gérer
alors évidemment dès que ce genre de
calibre bouge ça fait les bagues donc
mais ça s'est bien passé
l'aca
[Musique]
retour à grez-neuville avec son album
enregistré ici
le musicien propose une country aux
multiples facettes album et gâteries
parfois quand free rock enfin en cours
un très large spectre
les américains font pas ça qui font soit
du bluegrass tonka musique
traditionnelle sans matrix en est et où
du 4e et nous on fait sur cet album là
on a fait on a fait spectre large parce
que les français connaissent assez mal
cette musique là donc j'ai pris un petit
peu dans tout tout tout l'effort façon
de le faire
c'est très bizarre le contraire c'est
relié malheureusement à d a des côtés et
qu'on n'aime pas
nous en france particulièrement voilà
c'est une musique de gens qui ont
politiquement
les réputations assez droite
voiron bien ce qui est dommage parce
qu'il ya la musique et des chanteurs
extraordinaire et les chansons
ordinaires il ya les musiciens fabuleux
c'est un bon ben c'est un monde à part
entière surtout qui a influencé beaucoup
d'autres c'est beaucoup d'autres
musiques et c'est alors ça vient
toujours un petit côté ringard comme ça
truc là chapeau moi je m'en fous
complètement je passe au dessus de ça de
la musique m'intéresse le reste
[Musique]
lui
avec ce disque l'artiste nous propose un
beau voyage musical destination créé une
ville
[Musique]